alright Game of Thrones star Emilia
Clarke is speaking to CBS News about her
battle with a life-threatening health
scare the actress revealed last month
she suffered several brain aneurysms at
the age of 24 after filming the first
season of the hit HBO show ahead of the
season 8 premiere she met with CBS
Sunday morning correspondent Tracy Smith
to discuss her scary experience so with
the second one there was a bit of my
brain that actually died if a part of
your brain doesn't get blood to it for a
minute it will just no longer work it's
like your short-circuit so I had that
and they didn't know what what it was so
they literally were looking at the brain
like well we think it could be could be
her concentration it could be her
peripheral vision I always say it's my
taste in men my decent testaments but
there was all these kind of funny things
and then for a very long time I thought
it was my ability to act you really did
really really really did that was a deep
paranoia from the first one as well I
was like what if something has
short-circuited in my brain and I can't
act anymore I mean literally it's been
my reason for living for a very long
time
you can watch Tracy's interview with
Emilia Clarke this weekend on CBS Sunday
morning